well thank you very much and thanks a
lot for the opportunity to speak here to
the organizers and I'm gonna tell you
about am i echoing oh it's just as good
okay I think I'm according to myself
okay so I'm gonna talk about an
invariant that's been around for a
couple of years now called the positive
semi-definite rank of a non negative
matrix and this is joint work with
several people so it's a collab
it's a union of several papers but at
the in the spring this year we wrote a
survey which you can find on the archive
and my talk today is going to be based
on the outline of this survey so
Oh
give it one more shot okay so let's hope
for the best okay so let me start by
right away defining what the notion is
and we'll see lots of different
mathematical aspects of this this rank
so the definition is as follows we start
with some non-negative matrix M let's
assume it's P by Q and throughout the
talk I will assume there is a matrix M
of size P by Q with non-negative entries
so plus includes the include 0 so these
are really non-negative entries and then
the definition of PSD rank is the
following so it's the minimum integer K
positive integer K such that I can find
matrices a1 through AP that I can put on
the rows of my matrix M they have to be
PSD so this is my notation for K by K
PSD matrices and I should also be able
to find another set of PSD matrices B 1
through B Q that I can put on the
columns of my matrix M such that when I
take the inner product of AI and BJ I
recover the IJ entry of the matrix M ok
so the inner products that these AIS and
BJ's make should be exactly the entries
of M so the minimum K for which such
matrices exist and the matrices are K by
K PSD is exactly defined to be the PSD
rank of a non-negative matrix a so let's
see a simple example so let's look at
this matrix M which is the derangement
matrix of size 3 by 3 ok and this matrix
has rank 3 the usual rank is 3 but it
has PSD rank 2 ok so that means I can
put 2x2 PSD matrices on the rows and
columns of this matrix M such that the
inner products will line up to be these
entries that you see here so here is for
instance a factorization through the 2x2
PSD cone so a1 a2 a3 I would put on the
rows b1 b2 b3 I would put on the columns
and then you have to check the de inner
products line up so just a quick check
for instance if I want to check that the
three one entry is one I want to make
sure that a three in eight the dot
product of a three and be one is exactly
one and that's true because of this one
and this one and everything else is zero
okay so this is this is the an example
of a PSD factorization of size two for
this three by three matrix so this
example is interesting because right
away you see that rank can sometimes be
bigger than PSD rank okay so this is now
on the other hand if you look at all
three by three what's it why should we
think that there's an immediate
connection between the or any-any
relationship between the rank of the
piece if you didn't have the PSD
constraints then there's a quadratic you
could think of just the matrices as
being yeah but that but the PSD con has
dimension three all right so if you have
um if you take another set of another
three by three matrix like the identity
for instance then the PSD rank is
actually three and we'll see just very
shortly that there is a certain range
that the PSD rank could have been if
sorry if the rank is three then these
are the only two possibilities I'm sorry
so that row if you have a three by three
matrix then the only two possibilities
for PSD rank are two and three and
hopefully you will start seeing why all
of this is true as I go on okay so this
is just a simple example and the basic
definition no I don't mean that I have I
mean yeah exactly
for a rank 3 3 by 3 matrix ok right ok
so since since this whole definition of
PSD factorization of PSD rank and so on
is a factorization result let's just
kind of compare it up front to what we
think of rank how we think of rank as a
factorization so remember that when we
calculate the usual rank of a matrix
what we're calculating is the minimum K
such that I can write M as a times B no
restriction on what's inside a and B
such that a is a P by K matrix and B is
a K by Q matrix so I want to factorize
my M
as a and B where I want to minimize the
intermediate dimension which is K and
that's exactly what we call rank and if
we reformulate the slightly then what
we're saying is I can think of the rows
of this matrix a as vectors a1 through
AP that live in RK and I can think of
the columns of the matrix B as vectors B
1 through B Q that live in the
orthogonal and in the dual space are K
star and what I'm asking for is M IJ is
equal to AI BJ right so this is exactly
what rank is and this is basically we're
asking for the factorization of a matrix
through subspaces right so we are given
the set of euclidean subspaces and we
are asking for the smallest subspace and
this family through which I can
factorize my matrix and similarly PhD
rank you should think of as
factorizations through cones as opposed
to through soft spaces so that might
help actually okay so so here's a
general definition of what we call the
corn rank of a matrix and this was
introduced in a paper by Zhao Pablo and
myself in some years ago appeared last
year and here what we do is we take a
family of course they have to be closed
in the sense that if you look at a face
of the family it again has to be in the
family that's important so for instance
non- orphans have this property every
face of a non- orphaned is a smaller
non-negative negative or thing the PSD
cone has this property every face is
another PSD cone of smaller size so if
you take such a family of closed convex
cones then we can define in general the
corne rank of a matrix and that's just
the minimum K through which I can
factorize my matrix meaning I can find
elements a1 through AP in the cone
indexed by K and elements b 1 through b
q in the cone index in the dual cone c k
star such that when i look at em IJ this
is exactly the inner product of a and VJ
okay so these are Cohen factorizations
and on Monday we saw in Sanjeev Arora
stock the example where this family is
the positive orphans if you take the set
of all positive orphans
this rank is what's usually called a
non- rank and we write this I'm gonna
write this in my top with a plus at the
bottom okay so this is the non-negative
rank of a matrix and here now we are
looking at the family of PSD cones and I
have analogously this PSD rank and you
see immediately that the non- rank is
always going to be bigger than the PSD
rank bigger equal to the PSD rank right
so why is that because if I have a PSD
factorization sorry if I have a
non-negative factorization I can think
of every vector that I got as a diagonal
matrix which will now be a PSD matrix
and therefore the size of my PSD
factorization can only be smaller than
the size of the non-negative
factorization
okay so been hopefully this answer
something okay so so here is the general
relationship between all of these three
ranks that I talked about
so non-negative rank we know cannot
exceed the dimensions of the matrix
right because any matrix I can write as
M times the identity or identity times M
so I definitely don't need more than the
minimum of P or Q and as I just
explained if you have a non-negative
factorization you can convert it to a
PSD factorization so clearly PSD rank is
less or equal to non-negative rank so
this chain of inequalities is pretty
straight forward and then this is this
looks complicated but this is also
straight forward what it's saying is
that if I have a PSD factorization then
just you know string the L the rows of
the matrix along as a long vector and I
will get a rank factorization of another
rank function that like a rank type
factorization of size equal to PSD rank
plus 1 choose 2 right so if my PSD
factorization had size K then I would
get a k plus 1 choose 2 dimensional
factorization of my matrix with just a
vectors of that size so if you you know
rewrite that whole inequality then you
get something like this it says that
roughly the square root of rank is a
lower bound on PSD rank okay so as we
saw in the very beginning rank can be
bigger but the square root of rank is
definitely a lower bound
BST rank okay so small cases are very
easy to to determine so the rank of your
matrix is 1 then PS your rank is 1 and
vice versa ok there's nothing to think
about
if the PSD rank is 2 sorry if the rank
is 2 then again we have the situation
that PSD rank is exactly 2 and this
takes maybe a little bit of thought but
not so difficult to see so rank and PSD
rank definitely agree when for the
values 1 & 2 so the first place where
we're going to see a difference is in
rank 3 like we saw in the first slide
and let me do another example where you
see what happens to PSD rank for rank 3
matrices okay so this is again a class
of a family of 3 by 3 matrices these are
circulant matrices so I'm putting
parameters ABC as a circulant into this
3 by 3 matrix
they are non-negative values ABC and in
this picture what I'm trying to draw
here is how the set of a comma B comma C
partitions according to different PSD
rank okay so for instance when a equals
B equals C that's the only situation
when rank is 1 and in that case PSD rank
is 1 by this this fact that I had up
here and that's so so there's a line
coming out of the origin exactly going
up like that where rank and PSD rank are
both 1 okay so I didn't write that
everywhere else when you don't have a
equals B equals C the usual rank is 3 so
if the usual rank is 3 PSD rank can be 2
or 3 if you look at this inequality you
will see why that's the case so there
are only two possibilities
so the PSD rank can be 2 or 3 and PSD
rank is going to be 2 if and only if you
lie inside this parabolic region inside
this quadratic region ok so there is
this quadratic inequality that you can
write down an a B and C and then inside
this this quadratic convex quadratic
region you will get PSD rank equal to 2
and of course there's that line just
that's that's so you have to remove that
but everywhere else you will get pairs
do you rank equal to 2 so
this picture is a bit misleading because
it might make you think that there is
some nice region in which the PSG rank
is 2 and then 1 and then 3 and so on but
the picture is actually very very
complicated if you try to do this for in
if in the space of matrices in general
so in general we can study this kind of
question right we can look at all
matrices of size P by Q of rank 3 and
then sitting inside it there will be
matrices of size P by Q of PSD rank 2
and this is going to be some complicated
semi algebraic set in general with lots
of components and so on so this
particular case of 2 & 3 has is being
investigated by kya Kabir's and Alena
robee robee ba and Richard Robinson and
there's some very nice results like they
can tell you what the topological
boundary of the semi algebraic region is
what the algebraic boundary is how many
components it has and so on and pretty
crazy it gets really complicated and out
of control
but this example is nice because it'll
show up again in a more complicated way
um and maybe simple enough to see what's
happening ok so that's sort of the basic
relationship between rank PSD rank and
non-negative rank so now let me
introduce one more rank which may not be
very familiar and this rank actually
plays a very crucial role in this whole
theory and this is what we call the
square root rank of a matrix okay so
this is the definition so I still have
my matrix M which is non-negative now
let's look at all possible hard about
square roots of this matrix so that
means go to every entry in the matrix
and you're allowed to replace that entry
with plus the square root or minus the
square root okay so there are two to the
P times Q choices so there are two to
the Peter PQ hada mod square roots for a
given matrix so I'm taking entry wise
square roots of my matrix M so that tons
of them sorry
no no no my matrix am to begin with is
not symmetric yeah it's just an
arbitrary non-negative matrix a so we we
look at all possible signings of the
square root that's three uses for our
two symmetric matrixes and I'm a I M
equals bi and in the atom are reflexive
and symmetric same so is it like this no
well so if you do that kind of stuff all
sorts of complications come up it makes
it much harder if you require the AIS
and B ice to be the same then we don't
even know whether there's a finite K
whether there is a PSD cone of finite
sized matrices where you can find such a
fact it gets really complicated and this
this has lots of applications so we're
doing sort of general non-negative
matrices of size P by Q okay so what's
the square root so we look at all
possible harder max square roots and
then look at the usual rank of each
harder mod square root usual rank and
then take the minimum one okay so that
value is what we call the square root
rank and it looks a bit artificial but
you'll see immediately in by the end of
the slide why this plays a role in the
study of PSD rank okay so this is what
we're saying so for all the people who
love to minimize rank it would be really
nice to understand how small this can
get and so on so you're looking at you
know a whole cube worth of square roots
and we would like to minimize rank how
small can this get the smallest value
that the rank can take is what we're
calling the square root rank okay so
circulant matrix again same example as
before so as we saw before we know
exactly where PSD rank is one two and
three so inside the parabola it's three
it's two and on the line it's one and
outside the parabola it's three that's
what we had before
but now let's see what happens to square
root rank so square root rank is the
minimum of the ranks of these hard about
square roots and now what happens is you
get an additional surface that grows out
of the parabola it's like a flower it's
like one of these faux liam's it's very
beautiful if you rotate this
Mathematica and look at it and then the
the result is that the square root rank
is going to be less equal to two if and
only if your ABC lie on neither the
Powerball in the quadratic surface or on
this degree six surface this is a degree
six surface that shows up and if you're
exactly on that surface then the square
root rank is less equal to two and here
is the line right in the center where
all the ranks are one okay and
everywhere else it's two but if you're
like in the in the open region here
inside the quadratic region but outside
the flower then the square root rank is
three PhD rank is 2 so it is not exactly
the same
yeah that's right
okay so this is what happens to this
picture so this may be also already
gives you some idea that these ranks are
have complicated regions in which they
stay constant okay so why is this square
root rank playing a role in in in the
notion of PSD factorization and it's
exactly because of this fact okay so the
square root rank of M is the minimum K
such that I can find a PSD factorization
of size K of my matrix with all factors
having rank one okay so the AIS and BJ's
that we put on the rows and columns I
didn't have any restriction on their
rank when I put them up there they just
have to be in the PSD cone of size K but
now if you impose the additional
restriction that all my factors have to
have rank one frankly they are rank one
matrices then immediately you will get
this invariant called the square root
rank and it takes a little bit of it's
not so hard to prove that this is the
case okay so this is one definition and
then this is exactly why this plays a
role so we immediately see that squared
rank is bigger than PSD rank because I'm
imposing additional restrictions on the
factors I'm requiring them to be rank
one so it's an upper bound in some cases
it's a really good upper bound and in
many cases it's a really bad upper bound
okay so we will see examples of
different kinds but one fact that comes
out immediately which is a little useful
is this fact so if you take your m to be
a
zero-one matrix okay then let's see what
happens so if you take it to be a zero
one matrix then one of its harder mark
square roots is itself right I could
replace all zeros and ones with just
zeros it the same thing one of its
harder mark square roots is itself so
the rank of this matrix which equals the
rank of this positive harder mark square
root will be smaller than the square
root rank which is the smallest I could
get by changing signs therefore I will
get that the rank of the matrix is
bigger equal to square root rank and
square root rank was an upper bound on
this so I will get that PhD rank is
bounded above by rank so this is the one
very special case where rank actually
jumps in front of PhD rank usually rank
can be either above or below but bounded
below by square root of rank but in this
case you have this upper bound by rank
no it caught your seed control right
because of oh yeah it could be sorry
yeah it could be very very tiny so for
example for rank three matrices the PSD
rank can be arbitrarily high and we will
see what is this equivalence allow you
I mean I'm not sure I see a proof but
what is this equivalence allows you to
pick signs as to whichever way you want
okay so here's the proof so what happens
is so let me do it with so we're trying
to put a bound on the PSD rank of M
right so let's look at the square at one
of the square roots any square root okay
so now take a rank factorization of this
so this has some rank so let's say the
rank of this one is R so I'm gonna so
this is some P by our matrix this is an
R by Q matrix no restriction on the
entries of a and B okay now from every
row of this a construct this rank one
matrix and from every column of this B
construct this rank one matrix right so
now when I take the inner product of
these two rank one matrices
I will get exactly the inner product of
AI and BJ square okay and this is
exactly mij okay so from a rank
factorization of any hard about square
root you're actually producing a
factorization of my original matrix with
Rank 1 factors so it's a it plays an
important role this square root rank
okay so I've introduced all the ranks I
want to introduce now so let me just put
up a table that just compares all of
them okay so that's rank non-negative
rank PhD rank and square root rank and
since in this talk we're only interested
in PSD rank let me only focus on this
column okay so this double double less
than means that the difference can be
arbitrarily smaller or bigger okay and
if you have a single inequality and if
there's only a single inequality that
shows up that means that there is a gap
of the gap is controlled it cannot grow
arbitrarily big okay so for example rank
can be arbitrarily smaller than PSD rank
we will see such example soon there are
rank three matrices that have growing
previously ranked growing to infinity on
the other hand rank cannot be much
bigger than PSD rank because of this in
the one of the the first inequalities
that I showed in the chain non negative
rank can be arbitrarily bigger than PSD
rank not just exponentially arbitrarily
okay and the reason very nice example is
the Euclidean distance matrices so here
we take m IJ to be I minus J square
that's it's a n by n matrix where the
entries entry IJ is filled with I minus
J square this is rank three that you can
check it has PSD rank - because it's an
entry Y square right so since it's a
it's a hard amount square of the matrix
with entry I minus J its PhD rank is
bounded above by the rank of its square
root which is the matrix with entry I
minus J that has Rank 2 so PhD rank is 2
and then there is this nice result that
sure says that the
PS did the non- rank is log n roughly
it's easy to see at least log in and
then was a result of Pavel rubbish that
it is exactly log n state a log in okay
so this non negative rank grows to
infinity but PSD rank remains constant
at two no matter what size of this
matrix has so and the size of the matrix
n can grow arbitrarily uncontrolled
things then basically their ordering is
back is the smallest then PSD bank and
then escrow to Anton bumpkin no negative
are incomparable yeah
so that's true rank can be bigger but
not so much yeah exactly yeah so this
example kind of shows you that in
general you cannot assume that all the
factors have rank one if you want to
study psu rank if you put a bound or
lower bound on square root rank it may
sometimes have no connection to the PSD
rank like this example but in all the
cases we actually care about later with
polytopes and so on we don't have such
an example where the square root rank
and the PSD rank arbitrarily far apart
but for arbitrary matrices the entire
table can be filled and we have examples
of all possible scenarios in the survey
if you want to if you're interested ok
so this is what happens to all of these
ranks so now let me come to kind of the
motivation for why we introduced this
rank and wanted to study this so it's a
geometric interpretation and it's
related to these extended formulations
and lifts and so on that you may have
seen already but let me say everything
from the beginning so what so let's
start with a a convex set that I'm going
to call P it lives in RN so we say that
it has a phd lift of size K if I can
write P as the projection so pi stands
for projection of the intersection of
the PSD cone of size K with an affine
space okay so this sk+ intersect L is
the spectra hedron's that we saw in BAM
stock it's a slice of the PSD cone so
I'm saying that P has a PSD lift of size
K if there is a projection of that slice
that exactly matches
okay so pi is a linear map and L is an
affine space so here's a picture this is
the eloped oak the whatever the Somoza
the elliptic from the morning it
projects down to a square so this is a
PSD left of the square of size three
this is a slice of the three three by
three PSD con okay so that's the
definition of a PSD left now how can we
sort of relate this to PSD rank so for
that we need to introduce the notion of
a slack matrix so here's a general
definition so if I have a poly tope P
sitting inside a polyhedron Q then let's
assume that we are given a P by its
vertex description so P is the convex
hull of P 1 through P V and Q is given
by its inequality description so it's a
J transpose X less equal to BJ ok so
let's assume there are V vertices and P
and F facets in Q can assume everything
is a facet then the slack matrix of this
pair PQ is a V by F matrix so it has
vertices indexing the rows facets
indexing the columns such that if you
look at the IJ entry then you're just
exactly recording the slack of the ayat'
vertex in the J at facet so that means
you're plugging in the eye at vertex VI
into this position here and calculating
how far is beta J from this value so
it's beta J minus AJ transpose P i okay
so this is the slack matrix of a pair of
polyhedra one is a polytope the other
one is a polyhedron and I get this V by
F matrix okay
now this may look very specialized but
every non-negative matrix is the slack
matrix of a piece sitting inside a cube
okay so this is not a special
construction so anytime you give me a
slack make a non-negative matrix right
it as I can rank factorize it so I can
write this as a times B again there is
no restriction on what's inside a and B
and from this a I will get a P and from
this B I will get a Q such that when you
look at the slack matrix of the pair
this is exactly the original matrix M
okay so this is not a special
destruction in that sense so every
non-negative matrix is a slack matrix of
this type okay so then we have then
there is this theorem that relates PSD
rank to PSD lifts okay so let me give
you the theorem in two parts so the
first part is a little bit is the
general version so it says that the PSD
rank of the slack matrix coming from P
and Q is exactly the minimum K such that
I can put a projected spectra hydron
between P and Q okay so a projected
spectra hydron coming from the K by K
PSD Col in the middle of P and Q so I I
should be able to nest it okay so that's
what it is so if I have any matrix so
remember this can be any non-negative
matrix like an construct from it with P
and Q its PSD rank is exactly the this
the size of the K such that there is a
projective spectra Hedra nested between
the P and the Q okay now the the case
that's been studied a lot is this case
where P and Q are the same so you're
taking the vertex description of P and
the facet description of the same P okay
they are the same then the slat matrix
is what's usually called the slack
matrix of a polytope and in that case
the PSD rank is the minimum K such that
P has a PSD left of size K okay so this
is theorem and remember this is for any
convex set this is not this is not a
special and the history of this theorem
is like this so the second statement
that's right that they are the same up
to some yeah that's right but yes
so what's the history here so this last
statement here was proved for the case
where P is a polytope and these lifts
are polyhedral lives and PSD rank is
replaced by non-negative rank by Anna
caucus in 91 okay so we just call these
sort of general Jana Caucus theorems so
this so that was the special case where
he said non-negative rank of the slack
matrix is the minimum K such that I can
write P as the projection of a
polyhedron coming from a slice of the
non-negative Orton okay so that's that
that's the case Jana carcass fruit and
then what we did was to generalize this
to the case where P is a arbitrary
convex set so P is that and we replace
the positive these PSD cones with
arbitrary cone families and then instead
of a PSD rank you have to take these
cone ranks but if you have convex sets
they're not really matrices that you
have to take ranks off but operators
that come from these convex sets but for
the most part we'll just to only talk
about politics so you can just think
about the slack matrices as the only
things we will care about then we're
never going to be operators because it
can be a circle and that's right that's
right so the so the non-negative rank of
a circle is infinite right I can never
write the circle as the projection of a
polyhedron right so there are situations
when that can happen and yeah that's
true okay so this the the first
statement is sort of a generalization of
the second statement this is in various
versions in different papers the
non-negative version is in the thesis of
Osteopathy Kovich the PSD version it's
it's kind of folklore once you see the
first the second statement the first one
is pretty straightforward okay so that's
sort of the connection between PSD rank
and PSD lifts so if you want to know the
size of the smallest PSD left do you
have to know the PSD rank of the slack
matrix that's the message okay
all right now slack matrices of
polytopes are not general they do have a
lot of special structure they have been
characterized but I don't think we fully
figured out how to use that
characterization it so they have they do
have a full description by now but okay
so let's see some examples so here's the
day laptop projecting to the square
again so it's so the polytope is minus 1
to the 1 square and we this is the
description of the
elliptic projecting so this is their
laptop and then we are we have to
project that down on to the XY
coordinates the slack matrix that we get
from the square is this one there are
four vertices four facets and then if
you calculate the distance of each
vertex from each facet it's either 0 or
1 right either the vertex is on the
facet or distance 1 from the facet so
they are filled with zeros and ones and
the PSD rank of this matrix is 3 ok so
this tells you that this lifts that we
constructed here is the minimum possible
you cannot write the square as the
projection of a 2 by 2 PSD cone sliced
with anything so 3 is the smallest size
of a PSD corn into which you can lift
the square okay so that's an example
where P equals Q now let's change it
slightly so now let's make take P and Q
to be different so now I'm taking Q to
be the same square it's minus 1 1 square
but I'm going to shrink my P with a
parameter so I'm gonna take a smallest
square inside that the outer Square and
this the the sides of this inner square
is controlled by a and B it's a
rectangle okay and now remember what
disappears so if you calculate slack
matrix you get this big stuff okay so
here are the vertices of the inner
square here are the facets of the outer
Square and we have to calculate the
slack of every vertex in every facet you
get this matrix okay now if you want to
calculate the PSD rank of this matrix
it's going to depend on a and B so
remember what you have to do is you have
to be able to sandwich this projected
spectra
hydron in the middle and as long as you
can do this for and depending on when
you stick so you go through your
different cones and at some point you
cannot do it with the PSD cone of size 1
then PSD cone of size 2 and so on so in
this example it will jump like this so
PSD rank is 1 exactly if equals equals 0
that means the in Nepal in a polytope is
just a point and then as you grow your a
and B parameters like this PSD rank will
be 2 if a square plus B Square is
between 0 & 1 & 3 otherwise okay so
there will be this the ps3 rank will
move as you grow the inner square
because of the sandwich and theorem that
we saw okay so that's that's an example
okay so now let me say a little bit
about what we know about PSD ranks and
we know very little that's kind of what
we know sorry we know very little in
some directions we know quite a bit more
in other directions so let me start with
the sort of the lower bound side of the
story which has been of great interest
to lots of people especially computer
science so on the lower bound side we
don't know much so the one of the the
results that came out last year is this
result of brief deduction per Kuta they
proved that if you take all 0 and
polytopes
in RN then not all of them can have
small lives so small meaning polynomial
size left in n ok so there will exist 0
1 polytopes in RN that are forced to
have PSD lifts that are exponential in
size okay so how does this go this this
goes by Counting arguments so what what
they do is they say ok if I have a PSD
factorization I can always assume there
is one where the eigenvalues of the
factors are bounded ok so you can
renormalize your factorization so that
you put this norm bound on the factors
and then you count how many zero one
polytopes there in RN and you say ok
there are too many so if there if there
are bounds and these factorizations
you can't does not enough to cover all
of them so it's a counting argument
that's very implicit and it does not
reduce a concrete family of 0-1
polytopes that have this exponential
sized PSD rank okay so there's no
concrete family known so far with large
PSD rank meaning exponential in n zero
one and a lot of people are interested
in this as the potential candidate that
will produce such a thing so this is
isomorphic to the cop polytope is the
correlation polytope
it's the convex hull of all rank one
matrices a a transpose where a is a zero
one vector okay so no nothing concrete
about PSD lifts general PSD lifts of
this polytope yet so this is where we
are in terms of lower bounds but on the
other hand we do know PSD rank has to
grow okay so we do know some further
things so in the paper we wrote in the
beginning we had a result like this so
if the PSD rank of a polytope of is K
then P has at most K to the order K
Square and facets so you cannot have
keep on piling up facets into your poly
tope and keep K small if you grow the
facets a lot but keep the dimension the
same of the polity of P then you're
forced to increase the PSD rank so in
particular even in the plane if you have
n guards and you start increasing the
end in the end gone then you have to
have the PhD rank growing to infinity
you cannot have it just be bounded so
even in the plane you can produce
examples with PSD rank going to infinity
as you grow the number of facets these
are arbitrary and gods
4:01 polytopes what we have is basically
something like this that it has there
has to be 0 and positives that need an
exponential sized lift in fact most of
them I think have to have an exponential
size lift I will come to that in a
second - ok and another kind of result
these are just sample results that we
know is for instance if you take the PSD
rank of a generic and gone so that means
an end gone where the vertices don't
satisfy any algebraic relations then it
has to be at least fourth root of n ok
there are analogous non-negative rank
results to many of these results which
I'm not mentioning at all in this talk
so always three so this is a nice family
where you see right the gap between rank
and PSD rank and go to infinity ok yes
always treats always the so remember
when you take any matrix and you write
the P and the Q from it the the P and
the Q live in space given by the
intermediate dimension which is the rank
of the matrix and so if you're if you're
just working with polygons then the rank
of the slack matrix is always 3 it's
always dimension plus 1 ok
so so that's that and another thing we
don't know is we don't know any family
where there is an exponential gap
between PSD rank and non-negative rank
for polytopes
okay so for arbitrary matrices there
were you can create these exponential
gaps you saw the Euclidean distance
matrix then at PSV rank 2 not negative
rank log n right there are arbitrary
gaps but if you look at slack matrices
of polytopes which are fairly special
non-negative matrices we don't know any
family that has a big gap so in
particular we don't know for instance
where the PSD lifts are truly more
powerful than L peelers in in this in
this context
we end and enter the login yeah we we
know some gaps like that but we don't
know really big gaps right so for things
like the stable set polytope of perfect
graphs we know some gap like n vs n to
the log n but we don't really know
really big gaps ok enter the login is
upper bound on the non- rank of that
slack matrix that's in the IANA caucus
paper and n comes from the low buzz beta
construction separation for sure right
yeah we don't know it for sure but it's
right so approximation is different I'm
talking about exact live in so its
purity as it answers this kind of
question but I'm here I'm asking for
exact gaps between between rank and PhD
rank okay now there's another kind of
lives that we can define which are
called a covariant lifts where we know a
lot more okay so these are basically
symmetric lifts symmetric BSD lifts and
visa lifts that in in roughly speaking
respect the symmetries of the polytope
so if I have a polytope with a lot of
symmetry I want my lifts also to capture
the symmetry so it's sort of very
roughly speaking what this is saying is
that we want to construct very
structured lists such that if I have a
polytope here and it's being projected
from here and there's a group acting
here that keeps the polytope invariant
then if I take a point and I look at
where it came from so maybe it came from
here here's the point and I applied the
group action here so I go here this
should be the same thing as finding
another group element to act on this so
let's call this fee of G and then
projecting this down here okay so
somehow spinning the element and then I
mean sorry
spinning upstairs and projecting should
be the same as spinning downstairs and
then getting the same image from the
forth so these are equivalent lifts so
all these
their lives and so on are symmetric okay
there's symmetric lives and this was
also the type of lift that was studied
by Jana caucus in his original paper
when he showed that the matching
polytope does not have a small symmetric
lift and there are these this nice this
nice this nice result that just came out
very recently that shows that the echo
variant PhD rank of polytopes like the
cat paula talk for instance is very very
big okay so if you want symmetric lifts
then the you do need exponential size
and this was proved it's sort of for
slightly different definitions of
Aquarion lifts in these two papers okay
so symmetry does impose we we sort of
think that symmetry does impose serious
restrictions on polytopes like this we
don't know exactly yet but these are
very very large lifts that you're forced
to have if you if you impose symmetry
here's another very nice result that's
very recent so this says that the
equivariance PSD rank of the regular
n-gon is log n ok so this is uh this is
very nice
whereas on the other hand the the non-
equivariance of the regular n-gon can be
all the way to n okay so if N is a power
of a prime number then we knew from up
from the first paper we wrote that this
can happen so in the in the world a very
moonless in the plane in the plane this
is a non negative rank without the equal
variance constraint this Login right
regular yeah is log n yeah so if you
have non negative without symmetry it's
log n that's the bent all nemirovsky
construction and with this result is
saying that if you go to PSD but but
require for variant yeah exactly it
doesn't cost you much you still get log
in the true PSD rank we don't know you
think it's maybe square root log n I
don't know but this in this so just in
the family of n-gons you see that there
can be exponential gap between PSD lifts
and non-negative lifts if you if you
look at Aquarian 'less okay
so for a covariant
the answer the question I asked before
is answered the alakh dope is symmetric
yes
okay so um all right so let me say a
couple more things some almost out of
time so what do we know about lower
bounds in general so first thing you can
see immediately is that the zero-one
structure or the sorry the zero pattern
of the matrix is not useful to study psu
rank this has been very useful for
non-negative rank but the reason it's
not useful for PSD rank is just that we
saw that if you take the PSD rank of the
hata mod square it's bounded above by
the rank so if I take a matrix with the
Soudan zero pattern and I square it it
still has the same zero pattern but now
suddenly it's PSD rank is bounded above
by the rank of the matrix right so I can
never do better than rank this was
further studied by these Troy Lee and
dark ties and then Barbra York has a
result that also says that it doesn't
help too much to look at how many
distinct entries you have in your matrix
so if you have K distinct entries in
your matrix then PSD rank is essentially
a polynomial in rank okay so these these
things have been very useful to study
non-negative rank but they're not very
useful to study PSD rank so that's one
message and in general we have this sort
of lower bounding technique sort of a
meta principle using two results of gym
and so I will just say that here and
maybe we can improve this this this
program using the methods that been
mentioned this morning but here's the
program so if you want to generally look
for lower bounds like this M gone result
that I mentioned at the beginning then
what you can do is you can say okay I
want to project something a spectral
hydrant down on to a polytope so let's
put a bound on the polynomials that I
need to write the spectra he'd Rijn and
gym running guard has a nice result that
says you don't need polynomials of
degree more than k if you have a spectra
he'd run in the PSD cone of size k and
then what we do is we use his quantify
elimination methods to say okay if I
know the degree of the polynomial is up
here by quantify elimination I know
something about the degree of the
polynomials down here in fact I know
them an upper bound on that and then we
use the fact that well if I know the
degree of this entire boundary then
every fan
that the product of the not the number
of facets that you see here has to be
smaller than the done degree and from
that we get a bound the trouble with
that is that it's very hard to actually
get any kind of control on the constants
and so on so it's it's not really easy
to study the growth of PSD ranked with
this method but you will get results
like you know the end gone has to grow
in PSD rank in the plane okay so okay so
now let me tell you some of the positive
results we know okay so this is a
completely orthogonal direction which i
think is also very interesting so people
have been very much focused on studying
showing bad you know negative results
about psu rank PhD rank is very big for
you know whatever type of quality you
want to look at but on the other hand
you can ask when is this looked really
really good well for which polytopes can
we expect the smallest PSD lifts right
and in this case we have one theorem
that comes in the that's fairly easy to
prove that if you take a polytope then
the PSD rank is actually bounded below
by rank okay so as i said before for
general matrices this is not true rank
can be above or below the PSD rank but
if you take polytopes and their slack
matrices then the PSD rank can never go
below n plus 1 which is the rank of the
slack matrix okay so there's a hard
lower bound and then we can ask when do
you get equality but so the best you can
do is if you have an n-dimensional
polytope you can lift it into the PSD
cone of size n plus 1 so when can you
exactly do that and you can do that
exactly when the square root rank is
also n plus 1 okay so this is this is a
theorem and of course to check this is
hard right because I need to look over
all finings of my square roots and then
figure out what's the minimum and argue
that that's n plus 1 so we're not
claiming anything about the complexity
but this is this is the structural
theorem and it's kind of interesting to
see how this works so in the plane
it's very easy to see that the only PSD
minimal polytopes in the sense of
triangles and quadrilaterals in r3 it's
a little bit more complicated so in r3
this is the complete list of polytopes
that have PSD rank four which is the
minimum possible dimension plus one is
the minimum possible and the first three
types prisms quadrilateral pyramids and
simplices they don't there's no
restriction anything with that
combinatorial type is okay but when you
come to octahedra there is a restriction
on how they kept they are situated so
the geometry actually plays a role and
we need something called biplane
octahedra which I can tell you later if
you like
and another very nice feature about busy
rank is it's invariant under polarity so
unlike lustre rank and all these other
things which do not tell you anything
about the laaser rank of the polar the
PSD rank is invariant under polarity so
it's very pretty and you get all the
Polar's will also work here's maybe a
familiar example so there's the Lobos
theorem from a long time ago that says
that if you have a perfect graph then
its peers then its it has a PSD lift of
size n plus 1 which is the lowest theta
body and in fact that that result is
much stronger the in the the only graphs
for which PSD rank is n plus 1 are the
perfect rafts and vice versa ok and
there is also some new results by Sanyal
and grande on characterizing mate ROI
polytopes of minimal PSD rank ok so let
me see what's coming get me be able to
stop after this okay so one corollary of
the study of minimality is this result
so using one of these minimal polytopes
it was possible to show that PSD rank
actually depends on the field ok so if
you look at PSD rank over the rational
numbers it can be strictly oh I got it
wrong it can be strictly bigger than the
PSD rank of the real over the real
numbers and this is something that came
out of all the discussions we had in our
survey and there's a nice paper by Hamza
Raja and Richard and this question is
but for non- rank we do not know if non-
rank depends on the field so maybe this
is a good place to stop so if you'd like
this like it's proofs for a lot of these
relatively recent non- ranked mountains
come out of reformulating things in
terms of information theory then doing
some direct some kinds of arguments
obviously when you have a very nicely
structured probably TOEFL is there the
definition is you know pretty different
is there any hope of doing something
similar for if you drank fountains on
you know polytopes arises from CS
problems yeah so here's everything I
didn't speak about including the
previous slides so one of the things is
there is a quantum information
interpretation of PSD rank and this has
been the focus of people like Troy Lee
and Ronald a wolf and also they trying
to use information theoretic methods to
put lower bounds or PSD rank but it's
not anywhere near well-developed as we
have for non- rank there's no negative
rank it has been helpful to show the
results of Ankur and so on that it can
give you lower bounds but here we don't
quite have that machinery yet and maybe
I should I will leave the so this this
is this was my special slide for Ankur
so I want to put it off at the end at
least the complexity issues if I can
take one second we know very little so
square root rank is np-hard to compute
and this is a very simple example that
shows it so this is a matrix with the
identity over here and these are squares
of some numbers and this has PSV rank n
or n plus 1 because this the identity
already has rank n PhD rank n so it
could either stay at N or go to n plus 1
and it'll have PhD rank n if and only if
the partition problem is true if you can
partition a 1 through a n so this it
reduces to partition P psi rank in
general is it np-hard to compute you
think
but we don't know there's analogous
result Bible verses using sandwich Inc
simplices between polytopes and so on is
there a very simple proof like this of a
buses result that would be very nice if
possible and similarly for if you fix K
and ask is is PSD rank at most K this
was shown to be polynomial time doable
by Aurora Thailand and improved by uncle
and this is also not so easy to see for
PSD rank because in uncle's result he
very much uses the fact that the
algebraic degree of linear programming
is one right that that we know that the
optimum linear programs are on vertices
they you can write them down with
Kramer's rule they are given by rational
numbers for PhD we don't know for SDP we
don't know anything like this we don't
know what come in algebraic degree can
be very very high as brand said in the
morning so we can't immediately
translate any of these results but it
could be that you have other techniques
or other ideas to prove complexity of
these ranks okay so brain also the rank
and square rank extends immediately to
tensors but it seems that PSD right past
you it's time to tense
is that that it's nicer than turns the
right because it's lower semi continuous
semi lower semi continuous and so on but
yeah and it does share this feel
dependence issue possible to make good
let's recap